[Music]
okay everyone so this is my review
of the handmaid's tale season four
episode
six vows this was directed by richard
shepherd and written by dorothy
fortenberry
it's another short one here only 40
minutes long
and this is only a 10 episode season
that's a little disappointing out of the
gate
but i again do like you're only doing 10
episodes to tighten things up but i am
surprised how short
so far some of these episodes have been
so what i was worried about in my last
review
is that having this cliffhanger happen
that we do not know if janine
died or not i said i really hope they
answered that at least
in the beginning of this episode and
they do not they keep this going
it's not even answered by the end of
this episode why that's frustrating when
a show does something like this is
because now
you're going to see half the comments
even on this video people can be like
well what the hell where is janine is
she alive or not that's what people are
going to be talking about until it's
answered
so you're leaving something that's
hanging over everything and it's almost
distracting in a sense like i really
feel like we should have got closure on
this
and why i say that is because the
justification for us not knowing
is probably okay you know it's a reason
that we're having
june here conflicted about leaving and
going to canada because she wants to
save janine and find her but we already
had that reason
being hannah you even seen the scene in
this episode where
moyer is trying to convince her to come
with her june mentions janine to moira
about why she can't leave but then she
eventually in the same scene mentions
hannah so it's like why did we have to
double up here what was the point of
that like just
close the door on the janine thing give
us an answer i just don't understand
this strategy here
and we first see in present day in this
episode right where we left off where
june has this shell-shocked effect on
her
she's probably a concussion like the
doctor mentions later on
and it's like she doesn't even recognize
moira at first
and she's so out of it and again because
her head's on janine like the audience
but i swear to god if janine comes out
from under a dumpster i am going to be
so angry so what's interesting about
this episode is the flashbacks are
really
blending in well to the theme of this
episode and the relationships we're
delving into
and we're really getting into the core
of this friendship between
moira and june them being best friends
we're seeing this flashback of them as
roommates
right before june's about to move in
with luke and mary luke
and right away in the first flashback
scene of this
you see when jun is getting a phone call
from luke
she ignores it and moira says thank you
so
again it's already setting up that
tension they had about luke and how
moira didn't trust him
but by the end of this episode you get
payoff for that
and you also get payoff for how their
relationships works and how
them being best friends why moyra is so
important in june's life and that she is
that friend we all need that's
tough love that we always kind of need
to hear what i found interesting
was lizzie moss always kills it acting
wise right
but even the best actors and actresses
you know they don't bat a thousand
so they're sometimes you're like huh
that was weird so i thought that
happened here when
moira and june are in this truck
and this is when the first leaving the
scene
at where the bombing was and more saying
like
i found you i often found you june and
just something so weird about the
delivery here
of elizabeth moss's june saying you're
just so crazy
like it felt like this whole
scene just felt off and it could be
attributed to the writing too it just
didn't feel full enough here that there
wasn't enough thought out writing
for june's responses and yes she's
concussed but it just did not
feel like june it was weird
so in moira's motivation in present day
to get
june out she knows how important june is
june's a different case here where
june's gotten all these kids out into
canada
and there's a different value to june's
life i am with
moira here not just because maura sees
her as her best friend she loves her but
she
knows that it's actually a smarter move
to keep june alive and protected at all
costs where
her lover una is not on that boat she's
more about
okay how much is her life worth and is
it gonna
risk other people's lives and she's
making this case tomorrow about
how we'll screw people over out of food
and medicine and they can't take her yet
not to come back for her but this starts
this rift in una
and moira's relationship because this
really disappoints moira and how oona's
reacting to all this
now there was two scenes i really liked
a lot in this episode and one of them is
actually here
going to the scene where moira is
convincing june to
leave and what i love about this scene
is it's a lot of stuff people have been
dying to say as an audience member to
june so you feel it through moyra you're
like yes
thank god you're saying this stuff jun
needs to hear this this is what i'm
talking about the tough love
and samira wiley is i've said this
before
possibly the best actress on the show i
put her right there elizabeth moss i
think she's incredible
and she's been underutilized in the show
and it really hurt her i felt that they
put her in canada
i wish we got to see more of her in
gilead she had more screen time
more interesting stories but they're
doing more stuff here that's more
interesting with
moira now and she's always a treat to
watch but she's like i'm not leaving you
again
don't do that to me but jun's guilt is
really showing here about hannah that
she's in the situation she's in because
of her and
really aunt lady got in her head too
putting all this guilt in june's head
and making her feel responsible for all
the bad things that happen around her
this also happens even stuff janine said
to her but i love him more as like well
i guess then she's safer without you
meaning hannah
and says they're like they're going to
look for you they're going to kill you
and kill you in front of her and she's
so right about that
and this isn't talking about the
important line that june needed to hear
that audience members wanted to hear is
that
it's a better idea to basically help the
people you love
from canada and not in gilead and i love
that line too reminding you she's not
alone and to
ask for help you know she's like look
emily rita luke
even nicole we're all in canada we love
you we want to help you
that makes me sad too because it kind of
reminds me about how much june has lost
in gilead this season just
again all her girls and her handmaids
and more smart because she's saying
nicole needs you you know if you're
doing the justification about your
daughter
you know your other daughter is here in
canada she needs you too so
june sees this as manipulation as she'll
say later in the episode but i again
don't i think more is just saying
what has to be said to jun to kind of
snap her out of it to the ultimate
purpose she has and
maura knows as a friend what june really
wants and that's to save people help her
daughter and she's
trying to snap her out of this rut she's
in in this guilt trip and
kind of see a better way to handle to
get to her friend's goal but we see now
in the flashback this tough love thing
happening here where
moira's got some great lines about luke
to june when june's like why shouldn't i
marry this man was a good job he's kind
good shoulders and more is like because
he cheats on his wives
and he leaves them when they can't
reproduce and june crackster is like
well he only had one prior life and i'm
not annie and she says not yet
damn another mic drop moment in the show
i love it
got her but it's kind of a misdirect
because
you might think these flashbacks are
setting up
wow if moira is right in present day
about the vice she's giving june maybe
she is right about luke and we're going
to find out something about luke that's
bad in present day but
i think it's the opposite because i
think the payoff with moira's character
here
and character growth is that she's come
around to luke now in present day and
she's the one
at the end of this episode that reminds
june that luke
is gonna still love her and has been
waiting for her and been loyal to her
so her views completely changed too and
that maybe there is that
way of being too harsh in their previous
life that could come from also jealousy
as a best friend
losing their best friend living with
them and things change we've all kind of
been in these situations
now june gets on this boat in present
day now it's the life aquatic with june
osborne here
and captain una informs moira that
wait a minute we got checkpoints coming
they're going to search the boat and
moore's like okay
now i got to squeal and tell that i have
june on this boat and in this team
meeting you know so many of them are
suggesting to just like
turn june in and they're all making it
like it's best
for everybody else but it is selfish on
their part too it isn't you know they're
not
really thinking clearly i think that's
the easiest way to go but moira defends
june here is making clear how important
june is
and you live more here because she's
every time june's ready to just
sell herself out and kind of give up
moira is constantly bringing her back up
and
saving her butt here she's bringing out
her friend's best self and i think my
favorite moment in this episode
was when moira is suggesting they'll
just hide june under the floorboard and
some guy goes they search those and she
says back how do you know
have you ever escaped gilead before then
shut the f up i thought that was
so good and delivered great by samir
o'reilly but you see everyone's fighting
june feels responsible for this he's
like just turned me in
my life isn't worth more than anyone
else's but this is when moira runs up to
her and is like you can't do this after
every battle you fought how far you've
come
you can't just give up so again i really
like this
relationship and friendship they're
really delving in getting the screen
time with
moira and june because it's been so long
now
where i start getting a gripe with this
episode is what we're supposed to feel
suspense
when everyone's standing on this ship
and we see the gilead chips are on their
way
the suspenseful music starts to kick in
we all know
that jude makes it to canada because
again my complaint about the marketing
of the show this year is that in the
main
trailer they showed way too much and
they already showed in the trailer she
makes it to canada so
there goes the suspenses episode and
wondering if she would get out or not in
this
time and it's annoying because this show
already has a huge fan base it's a
massive hit it's hulu's number one show
of all time
and i feel like that trailer was
insecure like they overcompensated to
give too much to the audience thinking
they wouldn't come back
if they didn't see some wins and her
getting to canada in the trailer but
it takes away now from when we're
watching in that
feeling of suspense because we know so i
just feel like it was the wrong approach
i think most trailers it's the wrong
approach in general to show too much but
i'd get it more if the show was
struggling but it's not so i i just
didn't see the point of that
i also wasn't crazy about to just have
this huge argument
about keeping june alive or not and
turning her in
and then when the boats are coming moira
literally
just says please to una and everyone is
around una too
and they just don't blink an eye and
they're all the sudden down with keeping
june aboard and okay i was just like
that was quick and not enough was kind
of said there in exchange or someone
would have snapped
any of those crew members like wait a
minute no way i just didn't get that
so then when they come to expect the
boat you know june doesn't look any
different even though they just said
clean her up give her a different kind
of
clothes nothing it just looks exactly
the same which is always strange and i
love when they
say to june they go name and she says
rachel smith i was like oh my god like
come on jun you're picking the most
popular name in the country
smith really like i just i couldn't
believe that i was like come on
but again when she's about to just kind
of give up and say what really happened
to her
moira saves her butt makes a great
excuse that's something to happen during
the chaos in chicago that's why she
looks beat up
so they make it through this checkpoint
and what's interesting is this is
when now they know they're going to make
it to canada
and it's showing you this flashback with
june and luke but it's actually showing
you too that
june on the boat at that moment knowing
they're gonna get to canada knows what's
about to happen that she's gonna see
luke
so she thinks of this memory and we see
in the flashback you see some insecurity
here in june
about luke now moyra kind of got in her
head and she's asking about
his first marriage did they marry in a
church because remember
june is a traditionalist in the past
here and luke's constantly comforting
her like it's not going to be that
marriage our marriage is different
also luke notices that she has a box and
goes what's in the box
and she says oh it's just a cocktail
picture i stole
come on june she stole moira's picture
that memorial clearly said do not
take what the hell but the important
lines
really in this scene are jun is saying
what if i can't have kids because she
knows luke really
someone wants kids and he says you're
not annie and i'm a very different
person i was back then
and she's like what if i am
disappointing you and i'm not who you
think i am
and he says then i'll just love whoever
you turn out to be so i think this is
setting up
us to see probably the next episode when
we see luke and june talk with each
other that
he's not this man that moore was talking
about that he used to be in the past
that people can change
and not to just mistrust someone if they
haven't kind of screwed you over
not judging someone by their past i
think again we've all struggled that
relationships before
so that was really good and it's kind of
getting us more on luke's side now
because he's not the most popular
character in this fandom
but it's showing you maybe we had those
concerns like moira had but now
he is a different man and that they're
angling him towards sort of
uh more trustworthy likeable guy here in
june's life
but this worry that's developed in this
flashback that was brought up before
tomorrow that
june's worried she can disappoint him
and tell him that she didn't bring
hannah back and this pressure she feels
as a mother to protect her daughter and
that
she feels like a failure here and that
basically luke would abandon her
if he finds us out so because of that in
present day she
runs to the life vote and she's like i
have to go back i have to get her this
is one of my favorite scenes as well
she's so terrified here of actually
seeing luke without hannah and she has
to work through her demons here it's the
wrong way of thinking and this is why
her friendship with moy was so important
moira just snapped some sense into her
and like i said it's that scene where
moira is kind of coming around too
because she's been with luke now and she
sees he's actually a good guy and she's
like hey give him a shot you got to try
at least right
you can't run from everything but let's
talk about the acting here because this
is again a master class of acting this
scene seeing samira while elizabeth moss
act together and what's so impressive is
a lot of acting like they say is
reacting and you see with samira while
his character has a perfect way with
moira
how she represents her in responding to
june who's doing the heavy lifting here
right but it's the little things like
samir wiley's got those little tears
coming in but she's always selling it
with her eyes and so is elizabeth moss
because they're thinking as their
characters
and that's how you want to act right and
you don't want to try to do too much
you don't have to worry about trying to
do too much or too little because you're
again so
in there and you're buying it as the
audience member that they are them and
that
you feel you're there and you forget who
you're even watching it's that
incredible and
this scene to me was just remarkable the
acting
and moira gets out of like what happened
exactly with hannah
june's really opening up about her guilt
here
feeling responsible for everything
that's happened hannah and as a mother
not doing right as a mom and i love the
lines murderer has like no one's
expecting you to have her with you
they're expecting a human back not a
superhero and you see moore's like you
know
you're sounding like gilead talking when
june's just being really hard on herself
here and again that comes from
the trauma june's out of the way someone
like aunt lady has talked to her in the
past
so again you get that payoff you get
that character growth for
june and moyer that june's going to face
her fear now about luke
and his judgment towards possibly her
not having hannah
and also coming to terms with maybe the
better route is her going to canada and
saving hannah that way
and moira is growing at coming around to
luke but it shows that importance that
we've seen they've always had
just about friendship too and how
friends are always so important and
that someone that close like moira and
always being honest with you and
just guiding her in the right direction
and if you look at the day this
episode's a very transitional episode
clearly also because they're traveling
on a boat
but it's getting june to canada and it's
watching her best friend maura push her
there and get her out of this sludge and
guilt we've seen this character fall
into kind of
get her back into shape a bit get her on
her feet and we see now with the
flashback
june tells luke she's pregnant he's all
happy and excited
so it's kind of adding to this weight
her thinking about that because she's
like she knows
how much that is a happy thing for them
hannah this miracle they had
and now she's got to tell him in this
moment that
she doesn't have her but look he's
accepting he's hugging her
it seems all good and he
walks june across the border into
canada again this would have hit way
harder if we didn't know she already
makes it to canada and the trailers
thank you trailers
and it's strange like i am in this boat
now where
no pun intended with the boat that's the
second time i said boat like that but
i'm wondering what is gonna happen here
because it feels like it's almost
wrapping the show in general right like
i always felt that way when jun gets to
canada like
is this it like are we ending this
obviously we're not because this show's
going to go on for seasons they've
already said that again it's hulu's baby
they're going to milk it
and you got the testament so you're
going to that series but
i hope it's interesting i'm a little
worried but i can't judge you yet we
haven't seen the next episodes yet so
i'm just curious how they're gonna do
this especially with having
conflict now but now it feels like we
are going to get into resolution but
maybe not i don't really know
i'm talking a lot here but let's see but
again i actually thought this episode
was pretty good i'd give it an 8.3
i don't think a lot of the stuff on the
boat was that great i think you had
those two great scenes
with moira in present day talking to
june but everything else was kind of
forgettable and
just not the best i don't know it just
didn't feel
like handmade's quality type of material
i still think it's pretty good though
and still maybe a little
even weaker than last week's which i
said was the week is so far so i do feel
like we're kind of going on a little bit
of a downturn
here and that it's like i don't know i
i can't put my finger on it but i'm just
a little worried i don't know but
we'll see so i think that they're
setting up crazy couple last episodes
here
at the end of the day i just hope that
they don't hit a wall and resolve
too much that we can't justifiably make
some really good story lines
to go and that maybe it might just feel
like we should end this thing so we'll
see i hope not but
and honestly i'm still very annoyed
about the janine thing again
we gotta find out soon what is going on
with her they can't just leave this like
in the air because people are gonna keep
talking about it's too big of a
character to just
put that to the side and put it on a
shelf we need to know now so come on
but let me know down below what you
thought this episode i'd love to hear
your thoughts i read every comment i try
to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews in the
handmaid's tale i also do celebrity
interviews with the cast
and i also do other reviews of tv shows
and movies as well and
please follow me at steve all the show
on twitter instagram for more of me
appreciate every single one of you
and like i said even just subscribing
the channel helps me in so many ways you
have no idea
so i really appreciate that until next
week
praise be